hi my name is Apostolou doxiadis I'm a
writer I'm a Greek by birth and by
upbringing I am a European by culture
and spirit
and I try in my books to understand
things that are very close of the
European tradition as is struggle of
ideas the interaction of ideas and
personalities and how the stories we
live and the stories we make are also
made up not just of our acts and our
material environment but our cultural
environment our ideas I'll tell you more
about this in amsterdam on jun 6 at the
nexus important the theme of the nexus
important is this we up and I am
European and I think it's an extremely
important theme for this normal with
this age this time for Europe and also
vs special so I'll say now agrees I'm
speaking as a European but also as a
Greek is a European and who wants and
believes a big European and i think that
the importance of this approach is that
it will bring together fingers and
people who are passionate about the
issues of Europe and for the European
Union or necessary for it or for or
against I should say and they are going
to discuss we are going to discuss what
there is that unites us in Europe what
is necessary for this to continue to
unite us politically what are the
cultural roots what are the historical
roots and what is the present political
situation around the European Union
which is certainly very different should
we go forward to a more political
unification should we stop here should
you go backwards and this disband the
European Union in order to further
protect the European idea all these I
huge and other questions that cannot be
answered simply I'm not sure that
everything will be solved exactly all 26
but I do hope that would go in a certain
important direction and understanding
the question is better and finding some
common positions in the common ground on
which people from
European nations and cultures and stand
and feel Europeans